i don't believe we've met
it's me
foxy foxy cleopatra they called and said
i was foxy cleopatra
and i was so excited i screamed and
hollered and we had a whole little
celebration in the car
[Music]
my first time performing because i'm
performing and the girls weren't there
so i was nervous about that i met with
her and i thought she was really great
she's just one of the nicest persons
i've ever met i think in many ways she
steals the picture she's so hot
the fire department can't stand it me
and mike in between takes we do all kind
of dances me and mike had whistling
contests and we've made animal noises
i know i sound crazy but we did the most
crazy things very shagadelic baby yeah
mike myers played four characters in the
sequel about the groovy world-class
playboy and secret agent
how can i find this gold member it was a
movie with superstar cameos including
tom cruise gwyneth paltrow and britney
spears
oops
i did it again baby we wrote their
actual names into the script in the most
cheeky
wouldn't it be funniest everybody that
we asked to be in the movie
showed up
we got to watch austin and foxy's
romance play out but it was this scene
with dr evil's mini me that created all
the buzz no enemy oh i mean it's just
it's a little unusual i felt like a
puppy or something we had to keep doing
it that particular scene i did not want
to do but i did it anyway
[Music]
and b worked out the fashion channeling
pam grier with nearly a dozen outfits in
the film
you have the right to remain sexy sugar
oh i remember seeing the sketches and
being so excited and when they
transformed me into foxy they turned me
around i was like oh my god i'm my mom
and she stayed true to herself
reportedly asking for a redo of the gold
member poster because she was made to
look too skinny well
all i know is mama only got a taste of
honey
but she wanted the whole beehive
oh bee hi
[Music]